The Truth About Snakebites and Sucking Out
the Venom
There are a number of productive things you
can do to help a snakebite victim; trying
to suck out the venom isn’t one of them.
Actually having a negative effect, potentially
further damaging the tissue around the bite
and thus helping to spread the venom, trying
to suck the venom out of a snakebite victim
is an act in futility that simply delays proper
treatment.
Once in the body, snake venom quickly spreads
throughout the victim’s lymphatic system,
and it is just not possible for a human to
suck fast or hard enough to remove enough
of it to have any real positive effect.
Likewise, experts say applying a tourniquet
is equally pointless (it won’t stop the
venom), can add to the victim’s pain, and
if left on too long, the lack of fresh blood
can damage (and even kill) the limb, among
other serious health issues this can introduce.
Ice is also a common home treatment, but recent
studies have shown that it can also make the
injury much worse.
Another common misconception is that snakebites
are extraordinarily fatal.
In fact, even during frontier times only 25%
of bites from pit vipers (think copperheads,
rattlesnakes and cottonmouths) resulted in
death.
One reason is that some of these snakebites
are “dry,” meaning no venom is injected.
Today, the worldwide rate of deaths from a
snakebite is around 0.5-1% of people bitten,
due in no small part to the development and
distribution of effective anti-venom.
For further reference, approximately 8,000
people in the U.S. are bitten by venomous
snakes each year, but only about 0.2% die
from it (many more people die from allergic
reactions to wasp, hornet or bee stings).
This also means you are about nine times more
likely to die from being struck by lightning
than die from being bitten by a snake in the
United States.
Even in Australia where seemingly everything
in nature seems capable of killing humans
and where 7 out of the world’s 10 deadliest
snakes live, there is only about 1 death by
a snake bite per year on average.
So what should you do when you encounter a
snakebite?
Several things, depending on your circumstances.
Protect the person by carefully moving her
away from the snake (and making sure not to
get bitten yourself).
At the same time, try to note the snake’s
appearance (so emergency responders will know
better how to treat the bite).
Call emergency responders or at the least
get to a hospital.
The former is preferred so that the victim
can simply lay there and relax, to slow their
heart rate and perform other helpful actions
which we’ll get to presently.
If you’re transporting, or are, the victim,
and the bite is to a limb, depending on circumstance,
a splint to reduce muscle contractions can
also be helpful.
If you are stuck in the wilderness and the
victim will have to walk out, first have her
sit quietly for a while until fully relaxed.
This helps to keep the venom localized in
one place.
Then get walking, but at a calm, leisurely
pace.
In the interim between getting the needed
medical aid, try to keep the victim as still
as possible to limit the spread of the venom.
This includes avoiding stimulants and other
products that either thin the blood or accelerate
the heart, such as alcohol, aspirin, coffee
and cigarettes.
If possible, it is also helpful to have the
victim lie down, keeping the affected area
(usually a limb) lower than the heart.
Cover the victim with a blanket and loosen
tight clothing.
In particular, remove anything constricting
from the effective area, like a shoe or jewelry
(bracelets and rings, in particular).
The bitten extremity will swell and such jewelry
may then become a source of significant pain
if not removed.
The bite area should also be washed with soap
and water or otherwise disinfected, to help
reduce the chance of infection.
It should also be noted that while bites from
copperheads, rattlesnakes and cottonmouths
are sufficiently painful from the start that
the victim will ask for assistance, with coral
snakes, some victims have made the mistake
of thinking the bite caused little harm.
According to the National Library of Medicine,
it is common for symptoms from the venomous
bite of a coral snake to take several hours
to appear.
While you’ll usually be fine, so long as
you receive proper medical care after being
bitten, there is the notable exception of
the Black Mamba.
Residing in certain parts of Africa, you’ll
want to avoid these at all costs.
The Black Mamba’s kill rate after a strike
is 100% unless very large amounts of anti-venom
(typically 10-12 vials) are administered very
shortly after being bitten.
You don’t have a lot of time with this one.
Given how quickly its venom can kill (as quickly
as 10 minutes, though sometimes it takes a
few hours, depending on how much is injected;
the average time until death after a bite
is around 30-60 minutes), around 95% of people
still die from Black Mamba bites usually due
to being unable to get the anti-venom administered
in time.
For reference, one single strike from a Black
Mamba will deliver around 100-400 mg of venom
and only 10-15 mg is needed to kill a human.
They also usually won’t just strike once,
but will continually strike whatever is threatening
them as much as they safely can before it
stops moving.
If it’s a large, dangerous animal they’re
striking, they may only strike a few times
in quick succession, then may or may not follow
the animal until it dies.
If they do follow, they usually will continue
to strike only when they see safe opportunities.
As you might expect from this, Black Mamba’s
are near top of the food chain, outside of
humans.
What’s particularly frightening about this
snake, apart from being amazingly deadly and
8-14 feet long, is that the Black Mamba can
also move as fast as 14 mph, with an average
top speed in the range of 10 mph to 12 mph.
In either case, this makes them the fastest
snake in the world.
They can also maintain speeds of around 6-7
mph for lengthy periods.
If all this wasn’t bad enough, the Black
Mamba is considered to be the most aggressive
snake in the world.
However, it should be noted that even having
the reputation of being extremely aggressive,
it usually only attacks humans when it feels
cornered or when a female is protecting her
eggs.
When it does feel like fighting, it’s incredibly
fearsome.
Because of its size, ground speed, and agility;
how quickly it can strike; how fearless it
can appear to be; and how deadly its venom
is it generally takes a group of people working
together to kill one, and even then it’s
a dangerous endeavor.
So you’ll not want to encounter one of these
alone, whether on land or in the water.
In both cases, best to have someone with you
that
you can run faster than!